[Musique]
dans l'actualité de ce mardi 9 juillet
les suites de la pollution de la senne
elle a été engendrée par l'incendié de
l'usiné de traitement des eaux usées
près de saint germain en laye
catastrophe environnementale avec la
mort de plusieurs tonnes de poissons
lors d'une réunion donnée par le préfet
des yvelines hier et les élus et
associations ont pu faire part de leur
colère et inquiétude
suite et fin du projet riz dit c'est en
contre transnationales sur le thème de
la citoyenneté en zone rurale après la
suède et la grèce la délégation de la
maison de l'europe des yvelines s'est
rendu en pologne est découverte sur
place d'un musée école d'un ranch et
deux produits locaux et puis un dimanche
à l'ombre d'un jardin la maison elsa
triolet aragon proposait des activités
spectacles et ateliers au programme pour
célébrer l'été
[Musique]
heureusement pour vous vous ne sentez
pas l'odeur nauséabonde qui règne ici à
conflans sainte honorine
une odeur du au poisson mort trois
tonnes de poissons décédées ont été
recueillis par bateau ce week-end entre
hr et le barrage d'andrésy la récolte
continue
plusieurs tonnes de poissons asphyxié
angui flottante ou perche mortes ont été
repêchés dans les eaux de la senne suite
à l' incendie de la station d'épuration
d'achères les résidents des péniches
constate les dégâts de plusieurs colis
ça dure comme ça mercredi soir avec un
petit bateau qui à côté de moi on était
monté dans l'île il ya des deux agents
du siaap qui sont venus et ils ont vu il
y avait des milliers de poissons qui est
à la surface en train de respirer qui
essayait de se sauver
même les anguilles sortait de l'eau pour
monter sur la berge pour pouvoir
échapper à la pollution au décompte mais
plus laver le bateau peut rien faire à
part aux et des plantes rien du tout ils
ras-le-bol lincendie du site qui traite
60% des eaux usées de l'agglomération
parisienne et le troisième depuis
février 2018
une réunion d'information s'est déroulée
à la sous-préfecture de
saint-germain-en-laye
nous avons évoqué différentes questions
notamment celle d
mesure et de l'eau et de l'air aucune
toxicité pour l'air et dans l'eau
aucune des données n'est maintenant
dépasser et à nous
aucune n'est dangereuse une catastrophe
naturelle déplorable pour la
biodiversité de la scène selon les
associations ont géré directement les 6
premiers kilomètres qui sont la sortie
déroger de la station d'épuration et on
considère que 99 % de mortalité sur ces
6 km ces poissons là ils ont aussi donc
ils servent de sources alimentaires dans
toute une chaîne alimentaire qui va
concerner d'autres espèces animales que
des poissons la cciab s'engage à
continuer d'enlever les poissons morts
ainsi carré empoissonné la scène nous
allons bien sûr travailler de concert
avec adrien et les fédérations de pêche
de manière à pouvoir reconstituer ses
frayères au plus vite de manière à ce
que je dirais 7 mortels piscicole ne
soit plus qu'un épisode dramatique
derrière nous une crainte persiste la
température de la scène et de 25 degrés
avec un faible débit de 100 mètres cubes
seconde ce qui ne favorise pas une bonne
à réoxygénation de l'eau une nouvelle
réunion est prévue afin de faire le
point sur l'évolution de la situation
lundi 15 juillet à la sous-préfecture de
saint-germain-en-laye
[Musique]
découverte du folklore local les six
délégations européennes participant au
programme réduite avait rendez-vous en
pologne pour cette dernière réunion
consacrée à la ruralité en europe
la maison de l'europe des yvelines fait
partie de ce projet depuis deux ans nous
avons une grande diversité d'expériences
à la fois par la taille d expérience à
la fois des d'expérience le bâti des
expériences culinaires des expériences
culturelles de très belles rencontres
financé par le programme erasmus plus
des rencontres transnationales ont déjà
eu lieu en suède ou encore en grèce
les objectifs sont identiques partager
des expériences ou encore promouvoir la
citoyenneté active dans des zones
rurales
au programme pour cette visite en
pologne découverte d'un musée école d'un
ranch polonais ou encore de produits
locaux
cette pause rudy cosmétiques c'était une
très belle rencontre
c'est vraiment très important de montrer
les zones rurales en pologne
c'est très important pour moi comme pour
tous les autres participants
je m'aperçois que même si les
initiatives n'ont aucun rapport avec le
spectacle les problématiques sont les
mêmes c'est à dire que on voit plein de
points qui pour le développement sont
importants à avoir
que ce soit pour un musée ou pour
présenter un produit balle et il ya
plein de clés qui sont similaires et qui
pourrait être très intéressante à
creuser pour développer les initiatives
en milieu rural ce projet read heat qui
a pris fin avec ce voyage en pologne va
permettre l'édition d'un guide de
travail numériques sur le développement
local dans les zones rurales
[Musique]
ceci est un couloir de métro ou du moins
sa représentation un moyen de comprendre
les mouvements de foule avec trajectoire
la mobilité se fait exposition
l'objectif
voilà il au moins double c'est à dire
pouvoir identifier des groupes de
citoyens et c'est à dire partir de leurs
questionnements
plutôt que de faire voilà des
injonctions à la nécessité de réfléchir
sur une thématique de telle ou telle
façon non là on part vraiment de la base
c'est à dire des questionnements propre
des gens le deuxième intérêt c'est de
pouvoir présenter cette exposition et
les contenus qui ont été réalisés à des
groupes de scolaires à du grand public
voilà toujours en ile de france
l'exposition est divisée en trois pôles
l'individu le collectif et la planète
elle entre dans le projet questions de
sciences au jeu sociétés de la région
ile de france
quand on parle de trajectoire et
mobilité on a l'impression que on va
parler uniquement de voitures dans cette
moyenne transports et tout qu'est ce
qu'on peut en faire de cette de cette
exposition c'est finalement une
réflexion est peut-être un changement
dans nos habitudes de mobilité en
particulier je pense à l'heure actuelle
tout l'écologie et puis la sauvegarde de
la planète est quand même très
importante la mobilité c'est transversal
c'est universel mais ça se traduit avec
des outils des engins des systèmes
différents
selon nos situations selon les trajets
qu'on veut faire et donc cette
exposition trajectoire elle essaye de
nous montrer toute cette diversité et
tous les liens qu'on peut avoir entre
une mobilité locale urbaine quotidienne
démoli d'immobilité de tourisme conçu
par huit associations et un comité
scientifique
l'exposition est accessible à tout
public à partir de 6 ans un moyen de
prendre du recul sur le quotidien de se
détacher de ses habitudes
[Musique]
embarcation sur la rémarde pour ce petit
navigateur et apprentis poètes
on a fait aussi un petit tour en barque
alors le but on n'a pas encore trouvé un
le but étant de reconstituer un poème
avec tous les mots qu'on a pu trouver
sur les bouées
plus loin d'autres familles s'essaie à
l'art de la vannerie alors aujourd'hui
je leur fais faire des petits poissons
en osier et puis des dessous de plat en
rotant les choses simples mais ces
techniques de base voilà de la vénerie
les animations étaient nombreuses pour
cette sixième édition de jardins en fête
à la maison elsa triolet aragon artistes
et artisans investissent les six
hectares de la propriété des à triolet
elle est née à moscou et ragon il a vécu
à paris donc des gens de lavera ville de
la grande ville et je peux dire quand
ils sont arrivés ici à saint-arnoult ils
ont dit c'est à triolet qui dit ça à sa
soeur est dit j'avais raté la nature
jusqu'à présent les donc c'est un moment
important pour eux de saint-arnoult ces
deux fêtes synonyme de la découverte de
la nature et donc pour nous était
important que cette maison soit aussi à
l'image de cette préoccupation de la
nature qui aujourd'hui prend une place
importante
une dizaine de stands et des spectacles
de l'acrobatie dans les arbres et une
immersion des spectateurs dans l'art
ils en ressortent même avec un diplôme
d'expériences artistiques
pour l'instant ça se passe bien nous on
est rien et on est diplômé et c'est
surtout en fait un des chantres entre
l'artiste et les gens une transmission
vraiment pas un atelier de deux sons de
loisirs une transmission de l'art de
chacun pendant un petit court instant
une journée pour s'évader artistiquement
dans la fraîcheur de ce jardin bucolique
[Musique]
et moi de la terre
11h en ce samedi ensoleillé du mois de
juillet 134 personnes sont venues
embarqué opecst pour cette croisière
pique nique sur la scène une bonne
dizaine d'années qu'on organise ses
croisières sur la seine
c'est avec des clots beau temps arrive
les gens se précipitent sur ces
croisières c'est un moment agréable sur
la seine à bord du thier vanot les
passagers présents pour la plupart en
famille partent sur les traces des
peintres impressionnistes
on connaît pas bien les îles qui sont
qui sont au milieu de la scène souvent
on passe devant sur la nationale 13 en
voiture mais on va jamais au plus proche
développement également nom de la
navigation
découvrez aujourd'hui un certain nombre
de bâtiments et de lieux qui ont été
très fréquentés un deuxième moitié du
19e siècle par surtout par des ses
auteurs des écrivains célèbres comme mon
passants ou essentiellement par des
peintres surtout puisque c'est ici dans
cet environnement qu'est née
l'impressionnisme notamment avec des
toiles qui ont été réalisés par monet et
renoir régions les plus au nord les
ponts supérieurs et inférieurs du bateau
affiche complet pour la croisière un
voyage sur l'eau qui emmène les
participants le long des îles de la
scène de chatou à maisons laffitte
on était très curieux on sait rendre
compte de tout les différents endroits
assez insolites parfois
ça serait sympa
après trois heures de quiétude à la
rencontre des peintres et auteur du 19e
siècle
l'heure est au débarquement est au bilan
ce sont des passagers plutôt relax et
que nous retrouverons super intéressant
vraiment implique guide était nous a
appris plein de choses donc non vraiment
bien c'était très agréable
une balade assez surprenante de détente
en famille tout au long de l'été c'est
une quinzaine de croisière qui est
proposée sur la scène des traversées
calme et commentée comme celle
d'aujourd'hui ou d'autres plus festive
au son du jazz
[Musique]